transcriptomics three is a course
dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis that allow us to find
meaningful patterns and data especially
complex patterns that are present in big
data sets the course builds upon what we
learned in transcriptomics 1 & 2 in
transcriptomics 1 we learned how to
convert raw reads from a next-generation
sequencer into a table of expression and
then visualize it to develop a
hypothesis in transcriptomics 2 we
looked at statistical methods for
determining differentially expressed
elements that are present in known
groups of samples we explored the
students t-test bayesian methods such as
D second edge R as well as factor
regression analysis that effect the
influence of multiple factors here we
will explore different methods for
identifying groups of sample without
prior knowledge a process called
clustering and then examine methods for
developing classification models from
known samples in order to classify data
and new samples we will be using the
example from the publication by Damon
among others this is modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer which was
featured in genome biology in 2013 this
publication is interesting because the
authors assembled the dataset of about
50 different breast cancer cell lines
that represent the whole spectrum of
breast cancer variations the cell lines
have genomic transcriptomics and
proteomics data as well as an efficacy
measurement of commonly used and
experimental cancer drugs this course
will speak a lot about data mining with
the exploration analysis of large data
to discover meaningful patterns and
rules data mining techniques are used to
build machine learning models the power
modern artificial intelligence
applications such as search engine
algorithms and recommendation systems
the methods are an important part of big
data analysis and an especially relevant
to highly detailed biological data data
which has indeed been growing at an
exponential rate with unsupervised
machine learning methods we start with
the data set typically a table of
elements such as these shapes we can use
a clustering method for example
hierarchical
which is a method that seeks to identify
groups based on their similarities or we
can use a dimensionality reduction
method such as principal component
analysis that will assign samples to
groups of elements that are present in
some cases we can use these results to
draw other conclusions about the data
within the structure in this case groups
based on the shape of elements within
the group this is new information that
this technique generates one such
approach is PCA that uses dimensionality
reduction to show us what the data
variability looks like in PCA we use the
approach of principal components that
explain variance and our data in the
best possible way here is data with low
variance the samples are close together
and here is a sample set with higher
variance
however this variance is not well
explained by the x and y axes but you
could draw a line to the original space
that shows the maximum variance of this
data set this vector through the
multi-dimensional space that maximizes
the variance of the data is called a
principal component and just like with
the previous example we can add other
principal components such as PC 2 or
even PC 3 thus visualizing our data by
projecting it into a space of two or
three axes that explain some percentage
of data variance when we select the
principal components that explain the
most variance of our data we can project
all of our samples into the space and
visualize the full data set this
technique is called principal component
analysis and it can be very helpful in
the initial stages of our analysis
PC a to a photographer trying to find
the best angle for a picture that will
capture as much detail as possible while
showing us the most information about
the group as a whole we would typically
use this method to visualize as well as
explore our data when using this
multivariate analysis method it's
important to play around with the data
using normalization and filtering while
paying attention to outliers for the
best possible interpretation the PCA
does not identify groups or their
boundaries and that's when we turn to
clustering there are many types of
clustering and hierarchical is one of
the most popular approaches because it
allows clustering on different levels so
let's say we have our samples organized
in some space
imagine a PC a 2d plot where samples are
positioned in some perspective that best
represents the data variability the
algorithm would find the two closest
objects in this projection and then link
them together this is a cluster then we
would find the next two closest groups
of two where any two linked objects are
considered as a single object and their
location is the center of that cluster
the algorithm will run until all objects
are assigned to a cluster with all the
objects in it hierarchical clustering is
an example of an agglomerative or
bottom-up clustering method that starts
with attributing each sample to a
separate cluster if then finds the pair
of most similar samples and unites them
with one cluster that is further
attributed as one quasi sample this
procedure is repeated until coming into
one cluster that contains all the
samples the pipeline will take the input
perform clustering and put out the
result in several formats we will
discuss in a little bit in this course
we will explore various types of
clustering methods as well as their
parameters to see what the differences
are between them we will also discuss
how to best apply them to our RNA see
data clustering is also widely used in
data visualization to organize the
patterns into heat maps so that we can
visually see groups of samples as well
as genes
we will also learn about several methods
of supervising machine learning which
includes classification a supervised
analysis technique that relies on
annotated or labelled data supervised
machine learning takes in data that has
been labeled typically this is done by
people in biomedical projects
this can be clinical data or other
phenotypic data the labeled data is used
the trainer model and the model is
tested on a test data set this data set
will include examples of what is in the
training data but might also contain
additional variation the methods will
vary as do the principles used to build
the model for now we can refer to them
as a black box the method is essentially
to learn from the differences between
various classes that are present in a
training data set once this learning is
established you have a model or a
template that can be applied to new
datasets new data will have to be
assigned with a class that is present in
the training data set so something does
not fit the model such as the star on
the bottom right model accuracy will be
reduced the output of classification
algorithms include predicted classes for
each object or sample found in the data
some algorithms such as random forests
also evaluate how accurate and stable
the prediction is it does so by
evaluating which features if taken out
are the most significant for accuracy of
the prediction one such algorithm is
called binary decision tree their output
looks similar to hierarchical clustering
with each tree created by both
thresholds and rules
binary means the branch can either be
yes or no if the expression of the gene
is higher than X the classes will
separate the algorithm will continue
until has effectively separated all the
samples into some group random forests
uses multiple instances of decision
trees that are applied to portions of
the data one at a time after the
analysis
the tree predictions are analyzed and
majority voting is accepted this
algorithm is useful for more complex
patterns where smoother borders between
classes are needed it also gives an
output of most significant features for
classification another method we will
look at is linear discriminant analysis
which is a method that is somewhat
similar to PCA but can separate groups
into defined classes it also allows
certain flexibility for dealing with
data variability another important
method we will talk about are support
vector machines this algorithm differs
from other classification methods
because it is optimal to find boundary
of a class additionally it uses feature
space transformation with the kernel
function
this makes separation more efficient for
example a circular class border can be
achieved by a straight hyperplane if the
space was curved in such a way that the
classes are cut by a decision surface
these methods are commonly used in a
variety of biomedical research as well
as clinical projects with large datasets
are beginning to be more and more
available these include patient
stratification disease classification
and mechanisms of both disease onset as
well as progression on the pharma side
biomarker discovery is an application
for classification
additionally there are other
classification applications such as
target discovery as well as drug
repurposing transcriptomics 3 is a
course dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis that allow us to find
meaningful patterns in beta especially
complex patterns that are present in big
data sets